a dinner and then going to the top of
the roof and screaming I made
so I'm really excited about the idea of
people going oh no that's him and then
he shows up at the Pentagon and he's
totally clean shave and he's like where
do we start I I don't think you could
expect a
21 year old kid to stay a 21 year old
kid when he's 31. I didn't say like I'm
gonna quit music and
you didn't like no smoke crack you know
there's a little bit of murder involved
in in art why don't we chat we jammed on
E for an hour this is not a broken
version of success this is the new
version of success I want to listen to
top 20 and figure out what's going on I
don't want to fall behind it's going to
be a hit it's going to be a hit it's
going to be a hit and it goes like this
he's an American singer-songwriter and
producer by 2014 he had sold over 20
million albums worldwide his secondary
career Pursuits include television
hosting comedy and writing he's John
Mayer on here are his top 10 rules for
success
number one thing you have to do before
you set out on any other goal or any
other course is to Define your
expectations
number one thing on the outset of every
single project record tour Define your
expectations
everyone in this room wants to make it
but I question how you would recognize
making it
what is making it well what do you want
to be
who he who in here wants a record deal
would it be nice to have it would be
nice to have a record deal right we want
a record deal okay well what does a
record deal look like what does making
it look like do you want to sell a
million copies to a million copies well
okay let's say selling two million
copies is like selling 10 million copies
10 years ago so let's say you say to
yourself my expectation is that I want
to be an artist and I want to put
records out and I want to sell millions
of copies if that's your expectation
great then you sort of skip straight to
another questionnaire you know okay if
you answered yes to do I want to be a
pop star do I want to make music for as
many people as possible now you have to
sort of change your game to fit the
expectation you now have to wonder about
is your song shorter than four minutes
do you get to your core as fast enough
these are these are things you have to
absolutely do and you also have to
compromise and you also have to
uh play the game and by defining your
expectations if you decide that you want
to be a pop star that's not a dirty word
it just means pop just means popular
Frank Sinatra was a pop star
Jimi Hendrix was a pop star
lots of people were pop stars what kind
of pop star lots of people are Jazz
musicians what kind of jazz musician you
can be you can Define the genre any way
you want
so if you said you want to be a pop star
then you have to look at your songs
there's also people here who are a
little dishonest about what they really
want to be and I think if you want to be
famous if you want to make music for as
many people as possible just come out
and say it
don't say I want to be Indie I'm just
going to be an independent artist
and really secretly wish that you wanted
to be a pop star because from the from
the from the very beginning it's
disingenuous there's nothing wrong with
saying I want to play music for as many
people as possible without compromising
the things that I have to be as an
artist and that's what I've done
Sony Music doesn't come into the studio
when I'm making a record but I also know
what's going to be a hit or what stands
the chance of being a hit and what just
doesn't and it's a level of honesty with
yourself that you have to have before
you hand your music on to anybody else
so that's sort of one I want to say
about expectations if you only recognize
success
as a record deal and a big fat
Publisher's Clearinghouse oversized
Tiger Woods check and a dinner and then
going to the top of the roof and
screaming I made
most of you will be stunning failures
I've stayed pretty true to whatever my
instincts are as an artist sometimes
for worse at first
because I think when you do something
that's out of the norm
you have to keep doing it for a little
while to make it your own Norm
so it's an exciting idea to me that I
could be putting a record out and being
able to be my own person to not have to
think about what I can't say or can't do
because I don't want to lose people's
understanding of what I do as a
convention you know so I'm really
excited about the idea of people going
oh no that's him
that's him I think that I've got to make
a record that is the ultimate sort of
here I am you know so I think it's time
to go back
and um you know it's like in the movies
where the the ex-marine grows the long
beard and long hair and takes off to
like Tibet or something and then there's
always a moment I don't do that anymore
and then he shows up at the Pentagon and
he's totally clean shave and he's like
where do we start I I may be shaving the
beard soon I'm getting kind of this
place in my life where if if you can man
just do it you know I went I had this
moment where in my youth I was really
frenetic and everything was like and
then I hit this mode where it was like
less is more and now as I get into my
later 30s I'm like if you can do it do
it all the time you know you do it all
the time as long as you can do it do it
just shred show people what you can do
you know so it's a sort of this Arc also
of how fancy you think you are and find
yourself to be you know people on the
message boards and websites always talk
about he's changing you know I I don't
think you could expect a
21 year old kid to stay a 21 year old
kid when he's 31. so yeah the answer is
yup
change a lot
you know and I predict I will continue
to change you know but that's not a
that's not a dirty word and that's not a
dirty idea as long as uh that change is
reflected positively and being on stage
and playing and continuing the story I
think I'm right and saying that was
sometimes when you've considered
quitting music is that true
uh yeah yeah I've always thought I there
was one time in particular yeah and sort
of going on studying design or
something's always been a passion for
you yeah I like I really love design
yeah
actually I just finished making
continuum
handed it in and my manager played it
for the head of the label
and I was what do you say what do you
say what do you say and the call I
remember where I was the call came in
and he said uh
he doesn't hear anything on it he
doesn't hear a hit wants wants you to go
back and write some more stuff and I was
just like how can you not hear how
special this record is and I just
thought if I can't do this if I can't do
this I'm done you know and the record
went on to be really really successful
and my most successful record to date I
think and it taught me a big lesson
which is like listen to someone's record
twice before yeah you give a point of
view on it so now if anyone ever plays
me a song I go play it again
people a lot of times assume what it is
they must be saying to you and so but
that that day I thought I'm just going
to go to Parsons and and I love design
and I love where it's heading and I want
to have something to do with it and I'm
still amateur at it but and how long did
that feeling sort of disillusionment or
that specific feeling disillusionment
lasts for a couple days okay right but
then but then you pick it yeah a couple
days then you pick yourself up off the
floor but like I I didn't say like I'm
gonna quit music and
I must quit music and go to school which
I would have promptly dropped out of to
start my own design company
because I have to do those kind of
things I can't actually follow the
curriculum I I just feel like the the
process of starting over again which you
do every time you make a new record you
have to kind of it's a kind of a
controlled
demolition of what it was that you had
and uh maybe I'm a little I don't know
maybe I'm covering for the fact that I'm
frightened about
how do I follow up a record with another
record I don't I demolish it
and follow up with a new first record
you know I've never made a second record
in my life I make new first records you
know and I'm excited to
demolish continuum
you know there's a little bit of murder
involved in in art you kind of have to
it's a little murderous you know you
have to kill what it was
that was so alive in order to find New
Life somewhere else you know the only
way I know how to preserve myself is to
start the process over again I really am
frightened by the process of making a
record that people
really enjoy or react to that makes
ripples in the world and then go do it
again no
I'll do I'll start from zero again that
I can do to start from success and get
more successful is the kind of the
recipe for disaster
it's the recipe for unhappiness you know
I'm not gonna ever make room for squares
part two or heavier things part two or
continue in part two you know it's some
other thing part one everything you
learn is just raw information what you
should start doing is seeing yourself as
a separate being from anyone else in
this room you each and every one of you
now I want to go home and put it
Incorporated after your name in your
head you are now a being an incorporary
you are Incorporated you are now going
to take information and go ah I could
use that for this and that and that
don't show your cards to anybody else
some guy comes along he sounds like he
thinks he sounds better maybe you do
maybe you don't but work on your thing
and then you can figure out what makes
you you artistically and then you can
access information when I go into the
studio when I say them with an artist
I'm accessing information I'm not access
it's like a library I go I'm going to
take this out and this sort of like
being a DJ
this this will work this will work but
not by way of just playing everything
and that's what I wish people could do
more I don't know if you can do it real
time I don't know maybe this is just the
time you get everything and you worry
about sort of figuring it out later but
I think it'd be an interesting idea to
look at the information learn it and
then immediately start figuring out how
you use it or how you don't use it you
know a drummer is overplay guitar
players overplay singers over sing and
songwriters overwrite
so it's a matter of how you begin to
shape
anybody ever Jam
and they Jam too much
and they run out of ideas and they get
that itchy feeling on the way home like
they just gave up too much like they
just somehow
sort of empty I played everything and I
saw the end of my owning musical
existence from the dirt
I was just ended up in the in the rough
of the golf course I don't know
that's that is just a misappropriation
of what you know you've just all of a
sudden got to the bottom of the trick
bag and there was a hole in it you just
don't know why don't we Jam we jammed on
E for an hour I wrote I have a certain
Gene
in my body that allows me to understand
what someone else
is saying when they say uh we want to
sell a lot of these things like I don't
see selling a bunch of something
as the opposite of it being interesting
or important or meaningful
I've always had
I've always seen it from both sides you
know and it's a really interesting place
that I'm in right now like I I you do
have to balance
you know
if you saw my iTunes playlist I could I
could have a conversation with anybody
at stereogum or pitchfork you know
but what I do with Columbia Records as
the artist that I am with the records
that I make under the contract that I
have
I'm taking all of my influences and I'm
trying to convert them into pop music
that's my job right now it's not the
only thing I can do and it's not the
only thing I will do but as long as uh
I'm still trying to make pop songs uh I
want to play by pop rules you know I I
want to listen to top 20 and figure out
what's going on I don't want to fall
behind I I'm trying to
take all the elements of music that I
love that I'm well versed in
and convert them into music that a lot
of people can get into I don't know why
I do that it's a lot of people can't a
lot of people find the compromise
maddening I see it as another challenge
and I see it as another Talent you know
like the ultimate Talent of restraint
who in here thinks that the public is
mostly done
you think the public is mostly done
let me tell you something the public is
about 300 million times smarter than you
public is not dumb for those of you who
said yes I want to be a pop star and yes
I would like to have a record deal and
yes I'd like to make this happen the
first thing you should know is that the
public is always smarter than you
if you put a song out you go that's it
that's it watch it go light fuse stand
back everybody stand back it's going to
be a hit it's going to be a hit it's
going to be a hit and it goes like this
who is smarter than who
your big smart pop song went nowhere the
public just told you hey they're smarter
than you on that one because you said
you had it and they said I don't think
so and you didn't have it
so they're smarter than you
that's what you have to deal with
they're smarter
here's where the public is smarter than
you I wanted a song called come back to
bed I thought it was going to be huge I
thought it could change people's minds
about stuff no I'm gonna make you like
stuff you don't like because it's good
enough
I don't know about that
and the song didn't work and I was
disheartened and then they said what
about daughters he put daughters out now
I had thought again Public's smarter
than me I thought that that's just this
little song that lives on the record
that's like Track eight it's track nine
it's the one you discovered three months
in like oh this is here and they said no
they've researched it they really want
this to go I think it can be a hit and I
was like I don't want it to be a hit I
would rather not have a hit with this
song because this song is going to Peg
me forever as sensitive songwriter guy
and I gave myself sort of a three
strikes in your out Rule and I thought
daughters would have been somewhat of
the third strike the worst thing I could
have ever thought of was being the
artist where they go the record company
says look you give us the three we want
and you know we want and you can do
whatever you want to do I'm sure there's
some songs on Nickelback records that
Nickelback loves
somewhere in the back there 9 10 11.
I'm sure I've got to imagine
gotta imagine there's there's ones on
the set list when they get up to it
they're like I can't wait
thank God I was able to write those
other three that I know they needed and
I don't mind making but okay you know so
I say please I get on the phone with Don
einer at the time was I think sort of
just the head of all music
and I said Don you can't do it Donnie
you realize if I do this I'm going to be
sensitive singer-songwriter guy for the
rest of my life and I'm too young I'm
too young to be anything
but a guy who can put out whatever he
wants
I said fine fine you know I get it I get
it we won't put it out if you don't want
it we'll put it out and it made it out I
don't know how it leaked
but how upset can I be because at one
song of the year that year for for
daughters thank you so much for watching
I made this video because minia asked me
to I hope I pronounce that properly so
if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next leave it in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do I'd also love to know which of
John Mayer's top 10 rules meant the most
to you had the biggest impact leave it
in the comments below and I'll join in
the discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon
foreign